bernardo i i want to ask you this
question as well
are you from you're familiar with cloud
shannon and
of course yeah of course and yeah and so
the
you know the idea that we've been
talking about
kind of like what would be a hypothesis
in some ways of
what his work an extrapolated
potentially version of his work would be
i have a way to
to ask you about that process
is it the same way to envision
a zygote and the way that a zygote
becomes an adult and the same way that a
seed
becomes a tree and the same way that a
big bang
becomes a civilization and there is that
compact
information theoretical substrate that
does that
process and then there's and then is
there would you say
a recursive function as well
in all of those processes so you're
alluding to
shannon's information theory um and
communication
theory
shannon was basically trying to model
what colloquially you can refer to as
the amount of information
that is transmitted given a transmitted
receiver and a channel that has noise
and he modeled all that
the information that is transmitted is
inherent in the transmitter
so it's not created out of
you know out of nowhere um so if i
understand
your line of thinking you're thinking
about the information being implicit in
that
implicate order to use it as a metaphor
based on the word
the work of david baum
and that information is just unfolding
and becoming
visible exfoliating as an acorn grows
into an oak
or as the big bank grows into a
civilization am i interpreting it
correctly
yeah whether that information
well i i would say it it is an
implication of determinism
problem is determinism is not doesn't
hold
quite well at the at the quantum level
um
i would say that almost by definition
whatever
is whatever happens whatever unfolds
is the realization of an implicit
implicit potential
of the universe almost by definition
because if it's happening it was a
potential before otherwise it
it couldn't happen right
so there is a
at least theoretically there is
a plenum a a a
level in the hierarchy of existence
where you could say that everything that
has been
is or will ever be already is
as a potential and then
and then what we are interested in is is
how that potential unfolds and becomes a
reality or what are the influences of
that process can we guide it can we
steer it in a certain way
it's a valid question at the same time
it's an extraordinarily
complex question it may be
well it almost certainly is beyond human
cognitive abilities today i think
well in a sense
the way that you can take a a zygote and
that you can begin
screening the the embryos and
be able to to take even maybe multiple
embryos and
you know this is you know there's some
bioethics implications that that occur
here
but to be able to screen many embryos
and then to be able to identify ones
that potentially have single or multiple
point mutations that are causing
downstream
illnesses and say that you know
let's not uh continue the evolutionary
process of that
but actually these that have a more
that have better health outcomes but
also that we can you know
it is in a sense an a t c and g in a
double helix that can then be
reprogrammed
as long as you know we do this uh
longitudinally and figure out the right
combinatorics for the right
outcomes um that
we're doing an interventional process
that has these downstream effects so
in that analogy it would be the same way
that you can tweak
zygote's embryos and th is in the same
way
can tweak the existing um
uh making the model t a hundred years
ago and then
having the motor vehicles begin
spreading around the world or or now
there's a hundred thousand
or more commercial flights that happen
every single day across the planet
from the idea of like we want to do that
thing called flying
and so there there is a
there is a way to affect you know like
john von neumann would
would call it like this strip in a sense
and like
you are in a sense making a mutation
in the strip and that mutation
that you make to enable humans to fly
across the planet
for every you know uh iteration
of of human that exists downstream is
going to have the airplane
present for them to to
enjoy look the history of science
is the history of uh manipulating
possibilities and putting things to work
in a way you want them to work for you
using the laws of nature in your favor
technology is basically applied science
science is about figuring out
what are the patterns of evolution i'm
using the word evolution here in a
broad sense not necessarily darwinian
evolution alone
but in the sense of dynamisms things
happen things are dynamic they unfold
and therefore we can say that they
evolve
and the history of science is the
history of figuring out how this
evolution happens
and then putting it to use for us like
creating a model t
and now you know shooting humans to the
moon on the top of a big rocket
um did this
uh improve our lives
from a certain perspective undoubtedly
we live longer more comfortably we have
the means to do things today that
previous generations wouldn't even
dream of of course there are enormous
ethical implications for
further increases in this power you know
we stole the fire from the gods
uh we took the realm of uh evolution on
earth
um and in all senses even in the
darvinian sense we have taken the realm
now for how species evolve which species
will die
which species will live we decide we've
decided
that um for instance wheat would be
the most successful grass on the planet
we've decided it
we've decided that cows would be one of
the
most successful mammal mammals in the
world
now of course from point of view of the
cow that's terrible because they're
being killed and tortured like pigs and
chickens every day
but from a darvinian evolutionary
perspective uh
they are on top of the world there are
more cows now than many many many many
more than has
ever been in the history of this planet
so we've taken the rounds
whether we like it or not whether we
like it or not it's our decisions that
will
decide whether most of the species in
the world today will go extinct or not
it's our decisions that will define
whether we survive
one more century uh or not so whether we
like it or not you know we've stolen the
fire from the
the fire from the gods and how to use
this power correctly uh
is is a whole discipline in itself it's
it's ethics
how far can we go in manipulating in
nature
which is basically everything and
manipulating everything
um when should we stop and say well
we have the power to manipulate it but
we haven't yet acquired
a sufficient understanding of what we
are doing
in order to manipulate it responsibly
should you use the power you have
um for the mere fact that you have that
power
or should you enforce some matter rules
on yourself and say well
i have the power to change it but i'm
not sure exactly what i'm doing
so i will not use it i mean um
to give you an i'm i'm a member of the
computer retro community um i like to
fool around and change with this old
computers
if you would give a computer to a kid
the kid has the power to press every
key to press different buttons connect
and disconnect things
but chances are that you will zap the
computer
if you do that so the kid has the power
to do that should the kid
use that power until the kid understands
what a computer is how it works
how it's supposed to be used so uh
one could say the same thing about the
operating system of the human body
as well absolutely absolutely and we are
messing around with it
uh in in all kinds of unexamined ways
for instance we mess with our operating
system just by watching television
and we mess it in a very bad way just by
watching television
of all things by choosing where you
breathe your air
you're messing with your operating
system by choosing what thoughts you
think
and there is nothing new age about it we
know that uh
mind and body are deeply interconnected
in surprising ways
but by by allowing certain thoughts to
go
unchecked you are influencing your
operating system the thing is
when it comes to our to our own body we
don't have a choice
because choosing not to influence it is
in fact to influence it in an unexamined
way
we don't have a choice there right we
better get our act together
because whether we want it or not we we
will be influencing it
but the mere fact that we are living
that we are going about life
other things are not necessarily like
that um
so i i don't have the the ethical
ethical answers uh
to this um i'm not an ethicist um
as a technologist i i have
the intuit nothing too his of the
instinctual tendency
to err by doing more than i should
because i'm a technologist
and if i see that protein power in my
hands
the fire of the gods in my hands i have
an instinctive urge
to go and check and what can i do with
this to press the buttons even if i
don't understand the buttons
but there is my id you know my freudian
id
the supervisor in my mind who's saying
hey wait a moment don't give in to all
of your instinctual
instinctive urges because there are more
things at play here
that's about as much as i can say about
this uh
if it feels like a lot of that has to do
with
what has been quoted as this pause the
pause
that is what enables us to
be observant rather than reactive
and that pause when unlocked
the promethean fire to
pause and to observe and to
compute the combinatorial longitudinal
effects
take stock before you start messing
about with things right
i would i would say that look there are
certain problems we face today that
where we no longer have the luxury to
pause and contemplate we have to act
even if we don't know exactly what we're
doing for instance
um if i take climate science seriously
which i do i think we are no longer in
the luxury position
of pausing and oh let's see how this
goes
for all we know it's already too late
that the fact that we don't know it is
already an
urge for action and i would be willing
to endorse nobody's waiting for my
endorsement but
from my in my own mind i would be
willing to endorse
people who would say hey let's develop
some
technology to actively try to compensate
for the climate effects that we are
causing
let us i don't know let's blanket this
sahara on
is so simple in the sense of just
transitions
uh intelligently uh from
the use of hydrocarbons uh to nuclear
fusion
and all these other extremely uh
futuristic
star trekian styles of energy and
complete abundance for all and
for use the mass energy equivalents to
make
replicators and
synthesize whatever you would like from
pure energy um
and the this
it really is in a sense going like
like what do you
want for your great grandkids
in 100 years you know you want this
flourishing prosperous society for them
and for all
and so the question then is how do we
make that those incremental
architectural steps and
and why not galvanize the world
like one of the problems that eric
weinstein talks a lot about is just that
what's going on with our like sense
making apparatus around
allocating the brilliant minds with the
proper
incentive structures to things like the
sdgs
we know that solving these things like
the sdgs
is exactly one of the biggest
longitudinal
um success points that we want to have
yeah you touched on a number of things
that
that are my buttons so
very me look the first thing is
for as long as our mainstream metaphysic
metaphysics is materialism
people will not move to
better the world for four generations in
the future
because you know their grandchildren
will be dead by then they will not get
to know their great grandchildren and
they will be dead
and under materialism they will cease to
exist so it is all
quote immaterial what will happen four
generations from now and that's a big
problem of materialism because it
sort of stimulates this short-term
pillaging mentality
which is very dangerous but under
idealism
hey your great-grandchildren are you in
another form so is a planet
so are the birds yeah yeah no so you you
have any
you have a stake you're invested in this
yes yes um
now having said that the problem of
energy that you touched upon
and this futuristic energy sources
energy
is the key because you see we can solve
everything else
if energy is for free and abundant
everywhere we can desalinate ocean water
and have potable water anywhere in the
world
at the drop of a hat and solve the
freshwater crisis which is one of the
biggest
looming crisis in the world today um
recycling you know what the main problem
of recycling is is that it's a
major energy drain to recycle things you
need to heat them up you need to
reprocess them it consumes a lot of
energy
but if we could have energy for free
everywhere we could recycle
everything everything another one the
food crisis
hey vertical farms would solve the food
crisis what's the problem
yeah you cannot count on sunlight
because sunlight only hits the top layer
the layers underneath are in the shade
food doesn't grow but you can put
artificial lighting yeah you can put
leds and you can grow things
24 hours a day in urban areas to feed
the entire populations why don't we do
that
because it takes energy and energy is
not available everywhere
now the reason we got away from
the magical abundant forever source of
energy which is nuclear energy
is that it's unsafe and it produces
waste
that is the risks of store of storing
that are just unacceptable
but we think of nuclear energy in terms
of the 1950s
when reactors needed what we call active
safety
in other words if everything shuts down
then the reactor explodes
if you put the plug on everything the
reactor explodes because it needs to be
actively controlled it's active safety
since then we have passive safety
nuclear reactors thorium reactors wave
front reactors this technology exists
and these reactors are such that if
anything goes wrong
the whole thing shuts down no i mean if
if you pull the plug the whole thing
just shuts down the reactor doesn't
react the reaction doesn't continue
unless you're
constantly stimulating it in just the
right way
if fukushima has happened and that was a
passive safety reaction of reactor
nothing would have happened the whole
thing would have just boom shut down
with that wave
but that's fission and we have fusion
tokemax stellarator
that is even better yeah that's even
better but it doesn't exist today
and that's the galvanization of
resources and talent
um to tackle that yeah yeah but
i'm insisting on this because passive
safety reaction reactors
exist but the laws forbid us from doing
more r d and deploying them
now imagine for a moment that we could
deploy them these are reactors that
use as fuel spent
fuel from old generation reactors so you
would clean up the earth
by using them if we would deploy them
and have the courage to understand that
the technology has changed
we could deploy them everywhere and we
would solve nearly every problem we
could recycle everything we could grow
vertical food farms everywhere
desalinate ocean water
i mean the world would be different not
to mention the fact that we'd pollute a
lot less because these reactors
produce no airborne pollutants
anyway this was my pet subject
i'm so happy yeah i'm so happy you did
that
you're like there were so many of my
buttons pushed there i must
get this all out i love that yeah um
i want to ask about
if we observe
the the observers
that is this now
the notion that there are
a
an infinite amount of observers
and that there is
a there is a
a dimensionless singularity that is
indivisible and undescribable and that
there are all of these potential
infinite observers and that
there is an evolutionary process that is
occurring
in all of those and we can even just
focus it in on this one but i am curious
of what you think about those about that
other idea it's almost like that
the that the the the function
is to validate
the infinity like and that's
why the infinite observers occur
and then there's that evolutionary
process and then the idea is that
the telos telos of this evolutionary
process potentially baked right in there
in the initial
source code like we were talking about
earlier
is that telos to
oroboros is the telos
for the recursion or the the quine
um what what is the that telo so it's
both that
mo that that infinite consciousness
multiversal perspective plus the
italic perspective i i think you hinted
on at the answer already
and and i think you know you did i would
just agree with you
um just
on on the terminology um i think there
are infinite perspectives but one
observer like schopenhauer said
one eye of the world that looks out from
every creature
what is different is the perspective
what goes in your visual field in each
instance
but the eye is the same the subject is
the same i think
the subject in you is the same subject
amy if we would become a music
in an ideal sensor deprivation chamber
together
what it's like to be you would be
identical to what it's like to be me
and we would basically be identical what
changes is the perspective
but it's okay to talk about multiple or
infinite observers because that's how
physics defines the observer
it defines it in terms of the
perspective but philosophically i would
say
the core subjectivity of every observer
is the same so there is actually only
one
server yes that is that is then in a
sense
you could you could say um fractaled out
yeah yeah yeah you can you can
immediately get intuition about it by
closing one of your eyes
and then you know two perspectives the
same observer
that's interesting that's interesting
yeah
and if you put your finger in front of
your nose and you look with one eye and
look with the other you see that the
part of your finger that you see with
one eye and the other is completely
really different
yeah so there isn't even a part of the
finger that is common to the two
perspectives but the observer is the
same
examples very interesting even at the
child level can begin
getting that the only difference is that
in the case of what's happening here uh
the two perspectives
are separated but they are conscious in
time
or at least they seem to be i have a
friend
professor bernard carr who was first
student of stephen hawkins
i'm not sure i should publicly say this
but not that i started a
sorry bernard if i if i if i said too
much
he's working on a theory of time a
multi-dimensional theory of time
that may explain why or how
one subject can be many and my personal
intuition about it not necessarily what
he's saying
i don't know what he's going to say but
my personal intuition about it is that
we are the same subject in different
timelines interacting with it with
itself across
those timelines if that is conceivable
at all
yeah um so where is this all leading
right yes where is that acorn leading to
how would the oak look like
i am an empiricist as well um
so i take my cues from what i see
happening and if you look at the
evolution of life
which is the apex of cosmic evolution as
far as we
are aware of when you look at how life
is evolving and what is the apex of that
there is a very important sense in which
we are the apex
in the sense that we have become for
good or worse the dominant species on
this planet what is it that has allowed
us
to occupy this position what is the
unique
cognitive ability of our consciousness
as humans that has differentiated us
from
everything else alive in the world today
and arguably everything else that has
ever been alive on this planet
in the in the last three and a half
billion years of the history of life
i would say it's metacognition it's our
ability to not only experience
things but to know that we
experience things is the ability to say
i am having this thought as opposed to
just having the thought it's ability
it's the ability to say
i am the one having this feeling
as opposed to just having the feeling um
when my cat
is eager to go out in the morning
my cat feels the eagerness it's an
experiential state
but i think from from my cat's
perspective
he is the eagerness my cat i don't think
has the ability to step out of itself
and say
i am the subject feeling eagerness
i am not the eagerness i am the one
having the eagerness
um douglas hofstadt called this
stepping out of the system in his
monumental and magnificent book godo
ashabar
we have this ability to step out of
ourselves step out of the system
and then contemplate the system from the
outside and the system is us
but we have this ability to metacognize
not only cognize
but to cognize the cognition in other
words metacognize
so insofar as we are the apex
of the evolutionary trajectory and what
defines us
as consciousnesses is meta consciousness
in other words conscious metacognition
self-reflection self-awareness
then i would say the whole of nature
seems to be
pushing towards this ability to
metacognize to self-reflection
self-awareness to the ability to not
only feel but to step out of the feeling
and say i am the one having
the feeling and maybe beyond us nature
is instinctual
and it's overwhelmed by the flow of its
own instincts
which probably is not very pleasant it's
very probably very confusing
very stressful or perhaps
fantastic as well in other ways i don't
know
but it it's not able to step out of
itself and contemplate
it contemplate itself in the way we can
do that so perhaps
it is doing that through us perhaps we
are
those eyes that turned back and looked
back at the
at existence and said oh this is what's
happening
this is what's going on maybe the this
is this
universal metacognition conscious
metacognition
and we are just the beginning i don't
know
yes this is
where i could also include
some of the existing technology
advances that have enabled
us to feel even more like we are getting
a mirror of the nature of reality
and those advances are things like
artificial intelligence
they're like virtual realities um
simulation technologies
yeah so then that question is that is it
then or oroboros and recursive
is the is the tree dropping the seed for
another
tree metacognition is the ability to
turn your cognition
towards itself it is the aura bars there
is no better symbol there is
yeah it's when you stop looking out and
you turn to yourself and say oh
this is what i'm feeling this is what
i'm thinking that is the auroboro
boros yeah this is auroboric that's
super interesting and
so the relaxation of the awareness um
into the simultaneous uh
individual universal transcendent the
feeling of truth
when you relax the awareness inward is
the
epitome of the oroboros but then yes on
the
on the i like that a lot and then on
this
on the trajectory of where it seems like
an
automata uh orthogenesis is what it kind
of
seems and feels growing towards right
yes so look back at itself
and yes yes there and then there's that
auroboric moment
like you just described but then there's
another
like whatever ends up happening with the
synthesis of
ai vr simulation technology
wherever that ends up going uh there's
the transcension hypothesis
of going john smart of going
inward and that kind of solving like the
fermi paradox and stuff like that of
just
the oraboric moment of of going into
infinite designer virtual worlds and
just going into the next
the inner world which is the outer world
yeah yeah yes yes yes
this is rich territory um i think this
is a fascinating subject
to go back to technology um do you know
the oculus quest that's virtual reality
do you have one i've played with that
yeah okay
i own one um and there is something
everybody can relate to without a
psychedelic trip just by
using that of course the psychedelic
trip brings the same insight a thousand
fold stronger
but if you use the oculus quest for half
an hour
you become so immersed in that you take
it so much for granted
as reality it's the world where you are
in
that when you take it out and you
realize oh i'm in a completely other
world that's the first thought
and then the next thought is this too
just like that that's the next thought
what makes me believe that right now it
isn't the exact same thing going on
um you have that a lot with psychedelics
when you trip
you have the feeling that what you're
experiencing during the trip
is more real than real it is so palpably
and
richly and unambiguously real
and then you come back and you tell
yourself well that wasn't real right
because after all
what is real is where i am right now and
then you think oh wait a moment
maybe the exact same thing is going on
uh
i can either say that both are real
which is okay
or i can say both are unreal because if
you tell yourself that after that
unambiguous feeling of reality you come
back and you point at it and say oh but
that was not real
then what reason do you have to say but
this is
yeah you see yes
so yeah i think vr mind manipulation
technologies
are going in the way of facilitating
this kind of insight
which is ironic right because you would
think you know meditation and
non-dualism you know the eastern
traditions
uh they would not converge with the
madness of our technological society
but guess what
[Music]
oh man that's probably one of my
favorite
focuses is that grant synthesis
of the yeah non-dual eastern
spiritual perennial wisdom with
what is the rocketship of what
has happened in since the enlightenment
industrial
revolution towards this uh computers
were just such a massive
um unlocking it it may even be that like
biology has an automata orthogenesis
to create computers
um and an an artificial like we are a
biological bootloader as
elon musk said and i i think that's
quite
fascinating and interesting and then
the the recognition
that the west did create
a serious amount of
of a across there's just no better thing
for you to do
when you have a like a serious like a
femur
snaps or something than for you to go to
um you know like western medicine
medicine yeah exactly so
so there's that and then there's also
like yeah like a ai
is somehow in vrs and simulations are
somehow
synthesizing with like indigenous
and spiritual wisdoms of the planet
which is super interesting as well
so yeah that's this is such a big
interest of
of it's it's just that whole idea of not
dividing into two and realizing that
it is that it's the same source code
there in the implicate order right so it
shouldn't be surprising that it's
unfolding
going the same directions but somehow we
cognized it as surprising
uh look i i am an admirer of eastern
traditions
um no question no questions about that
i'm an admirer
of native american traditions um
i'm an admirer of african traditions
which are
i think unjustifiably
um ignored yeah because the african
thinks with his heart
and and and that's something we that we
need that color in the rainbow of
humanity
uh if you know what i mean um but
i am a very proud
outcome of the western tradition i don't
pooh-pooh the west at all like
many of us seem to do um i think
the western path may be misinformed as
it may be
or whatever you can say about it i i
think it is
a valid path it's just a path that
carries
more responsibility than everybody else
because
we have the protein fire in our hands
and we can end the game for everybody in
a drop of a dime
so that means that our responsibility is
greater you can even ask
can the earth afford the existence of
the western tradition
is this not too big of a gamble because
the payoff
is drastic the payoff may be
instant forced enlightenment 100 years
down the road
you know no need for 35 years of
meditation man
just to put this little helmet and there
you are
that's a major payoff but but the risk
is fantastically high um
that said you know i i'm a
proud philosopher in the western
tradition and i think we pooh-pooh our
own tradition too much we should much
we should honor what is ours we should
honor our inheritance
like uh arthur schofenhauer is
going all the way back to promenities
how many people know what feminism
yeah and how many people interpret him
correctly amongst the ones that know
what he said
i mean 12 scholars in the world
i mean it's ridiculous how much we
ignore
our own tradition while turning our eyes
to the richness of other traditions
which are unquestionable
i think the influence of eastern
traditions in the west has been very
useful very benign
it has given us language a conceptual
tool set that we didn't have
but this should not come at the cost of
our own tradition we are products of the
western world
yeah amen
yeah that's so so well said then there's
there's
always room at the big
buffet of union
this again yoga
does not mean holding a stretching pose
it means
union in sanskrit so please everyone
remember that forever
and at this big buffet of union
that there are all of these options and
for the for the parent to expose their
child
to the options and to follow the child
to follow their curiosity
and for the child to truly
dig the well to water in the sense of
realizing
that infinite consciousness at the same
time
as for them to be able to sample
from that buffet some west
some east some science technology
biotech neurotech vr ai
quantum sciences all the way to
understanding
what the buddhist teaching or or laotz's
teachings confucius's teachings the
african traditions
the um native americans just just
there's so much
richness to select from the buffet in a
sense the more
exposure also that you have at least
um to you know become leverage that
pareto leverage
only looking at maybe the five or ten
percent of all of those that give you
the
most uh like 80 or 90 understanding of
what the essence of it is
and if you get really efficient at that
process in education
then you become that polymath that is
able to
put on all of these different costumes
to engage with the world and all of
these different ways and
you're you're making novel connections
between fields that nobody else
sees yeah but you know in the process of
doing that
one of those clothes to put on should be
our own
right yes but let me give you an example
um
i think there is a profound point when
um
an invited teacher says thought is your
enemy
your monkey mind will just get you
caught up caught up in all kinds of
conceptual narratives and you will
completely lose
sight of what is right under your nose
which is who you actually are and what
is actually going on we get so
you know tied up in that conceptual web
so thought is your enemy there is a very
important sense in which this is correct
but you see the west has a tradition
that uses thought to get you out of the
web
uh peter kingsley calls this um
logic true logic um as opposed to just
reasoning um he he considers true logic
uh an enchantment it's a it's a way to
enchant your own mind out of the
delusion
throw some fairy dust in your mind in a
very subtle way
you see it and we have a tradition of
people using logic
to do that like um xenos paradox or
paradoxes
you know others so you know about it but
you probably recognize that there are
many people who never heard
of xenos paradoxes that's a way to use
logic
to tie you up in such an impossible
conclusion
in inner contradiction that it works
like um
that japanese hype no not a haiku um
how is it called again uh it's part of
zen buddhism
high quality
oh the like the one hand clapping yes
yes like that yeah yeah yeah yeah so oh
i
forgot what the word is but yeah if i
blanked you blank too i mean this
happens so far
right that's our known local connection
here so
xenos paradoxes work like that and in
modern science we have the tendency to
say well now we figured out the answer
to xenos paradoxes no we
we have the notion of limits and
derivatives and integrals we can make
sense of that
but actually you can't really because
you make sense of that by imagining that
you've reached
a limit that you actually never reach
because it's
infinite it's an infinity so you
actually don't make sense of it you just
postpone it infinitely um
and but we we don't follow that path we
say well you know
forget logic forget the thoughts forget
the monkey mind
there is an important sense in which
that's true but it makes us blind to our
own
the richness of our own inheritance our
own
tendencies our own tools uh to get there
and
you know i'm making a point of it
because it's one of my you know i have a
beef with it
uh yeah and i like to highlight it every
time i can
you you bring up what is probably
the most um salient and simple
way of endeavoring
as a more thought-provoking human
in our world which is posing
these questions of this true logic
where when you do pose such a question
it makes the other person uh
the com the does not compute um
emotion or or like the mind-blowing
emotion yeah it it
it's inspirational because it it drives
people to
to further inquiry that they
they didn't know that that those things
existed and like you said
there's so much there's so much malware
that is
programmed yeah and and we treat these
things
as mere curiosities like a little game
you play you don't get an answer for it
but then you just dismiss it oh it's
just a little
little game it's not these are tools for
for very
deep uh thinking um but we dismiss them
it's unfortunate yeah and then
rupert spires said there's this
difference between a
something that's not real which is like
the square circle
um or taking the half the distance to
the wall
um yeah that's the xenos paradox of
achilles in the tortoise
yeah yeah achilles never overtakes the
tortoise
you can prove that logically that he can
never overtake the tortoise
it just causes a tilt you know an old
arcade uh
games if you shook the machine too hard
it would tilt to stop working
so xenos paradoxes just tilt your
logical mind and that's how they take
you out of the story because you realize
that
if you follow the logic very strictly
it's sort of
short circuits it contradicts itself and
then there is a moment that you go like
space is not what i think it is well yes
yeah now you're at us
yes yes got it but then you immediately
come back
and there's these cards that i think are
another very interesting way to do it is
you
you take these you take three of these
little cards
and you put the words uh past present
and future on them and then you give
them to somebody and you say
um order them as you please
and then there are certain people in the
world that put them in
order of past present future like a
linear order
and then there are other people in the
world that stack all three on top of
each other
and and i think that these are also
those small
in a sense uh like
there's it's like true logic it's also
kind of like um
mind-blowing activities it's it's
questioning
the nature of reality in fun child-like
engaging
ways you could even write the number you
know i think
even people like takashi 69 have come up
with interesting things just put
the number six on the sheet of paper and
then you look at it and i look at it and
you see that i see a nine and you see a
six
and it's the same thing with the dress
the dress in 2015
about half yeah half of people saw it as
as
black and blue and half people saw it as
gold and white
and um when you when you um there's also
the
the necker cube and the reuben vase um
there are all these different ways of
if if you slowly incrementally
um realize that it's not that
your you perceiving the dress as gold
and
white is incorrect and me perceiving it
as blue
and black is correct but that both of us
are holding that truth like
that simple recognition so all of these
activities that we've been talking about
are all just
really solid ways to to bring activities
and questions
to adults and children to slowly bring
them towards a more awakened
state yeah i love technology vr surely
yeah yeah i love that